Marrs to the time when he guarded the
movies she can expect the story you see
on the big screen to be resolved by the
time the lights come up maybe not all
the good guys will make it to the end
but for the most part the world will be
as it should be but not every story can
have a happy ending sometimes the price
of victory is high and characters we
learn to love a taken away from us
other times the heroes don't win at all
no matter how much they sacrificed man
on fire may not have been a favorite of
critics but Denzel Washington's
performance as alcoholic bodyguard
John Crecy was one of the most moving of
his career after years of booze and
bullets
Creasy gets a shot at redemption as a
bodyguard for PETA
played by Dakota Fanning when a powerful
crime syndicate captures Peter crazy
buys pretty much every gun in Mexico and
goes on a murder spree eventually
capturing the kidnappers brother dying
from a gunshot wound
Creasy traits himself for the safety of
his charge but before handing himself
over he reunites with Peter for just a
few seconds when he tells their goodbye
it's a moment that will make even the
toughest action fan weep
[Music]
while the boxing drama Million Dollar
Baby may at times feel as inspirational
as rocky Rocky Balboa never ended a
movie quiet like this Hilary Swank plays
Maggie Fitzgerald a backwoods waitress
hoping to make a name as a boxer and
director Clint Eastwood plays grizzled
trainer
Frankie Dunn Dunn is reluctant to teach
a woman at first especially one as old
as Maggie
but eventually her persistence wins him
over Maggie proves her worth kay owing
away to a championship fight and that's
when the movie takes a hard left turn
Maggie is paralyzed from the neck down
when her opponent illegally punches her
after the Bell a hero falls hard from
the punch smashing her neck against the
footstool Maggie loses her leg and she
begs her trainer to end her suffering
Dunn refuses at first but agrees after
Maggie tries and fails to commit suicide
before Dunn administers the lethal
injection he tells Maggie the meaning of
her Irish nickname cushla means my
darling even steely eyed Eastwood can't
keep the tears back here and you know if
even Dirty Harry is getting weepy
there's no way you're going to be able
to hold it back
my auntie falls Frankie Angela after the
tragic death of bear enthusiast Timothy
Treadwell at the jaws of a brown bear
director Werner Herzog assembled
Treadwell footage and created Grizzly
Man one of the most moving documentaries
of all time Grizzly Man follows
Treadwell as he journeys into the
Alaskan wilderness interacts with
animals and shares his unique view about
a man's place in nature while
Treadwell's behavior is sometimes
questionable it's hard not to admire his
passion with the help of Hertzog's
guiding hand we grow attached to
Treadwell as Grizzly Man heads for it's
inevitable tragic ending while we go
into Grizzly Man knowing Treadwell
Speight it's upsetting to finally say
goodbye to such a unique soul in the
film's last moments we watch for the
last time as Treadwell wanders into the
woods accompanied by two fuzzy friends
and a mournful country song that feels
like it was written just for him while
where's Edna's and directs comedies
there's always a deep sense of
melancholy underlying his work that's
especially true for the grand Budapest
hotel set in the fictional European
country of Zubrowka the film's narrative
is nestled inside multiple timelines
with the bulk of it set during the 1930s
our hero zero Moustafa played by both
tiny revel or E and F Murray Abraham
works as a lobby boy
at the grand Budapest hotel under the
guidance of flamboyant concierge M
Gustav played by ray Fiennes the flood
involves the dead heiress and missing
painting and a family of greedy goons
but the drama revolves around the dark
shadow hanging over this dream world in
the 1930s the hotel is an impossibly
charming world of pastel colors as the
story continues both Zubrowka and grand
Budapest are overrun by enemy forces
quasi Nazis followed by quasi Soviets as
the totalitarian horrors of the 20th
century creep in M Gustav civilised
world starts to fade guests stop coming
and eventually the building is torn down
M Gustav is killed during the war
communism washes over Zubrowka and zero
is left alone
nothing but he's memories of better days
the film ends with the nostalgic author
saying over the closing frame it was an
enchanting old ruin but I never managed
to see it again on its cold grey surface
the Black Codes daughter is a movie
about a girl whose demonically possessed
but under the slow-building dread and
eerie music there's a tragic story about
a helpless child afraid of being alone
played at first by Kiernan Shipka and
later by Emma Roberts Kat is a boarding
school student with some serious
abandonment issues when a parents are
late to pick her up for the semester
break Kat freaks out it doesn't help
matters any when she has an unsettling
dream about a parents untimely fate
terrified her parents are dead and that
she'll be all alone in the world Kat
literally makes a deal with the devil
allowing herself to be possessed in
exchange for companionship she's so
afraid of losing the spirits company she
beheads three people at it's urgent when
a priest exercises the demon from Kat
she's so scared of being alone that she
begs the Beast to stay
unfortunately her pleas are no match for
holy water years later an older cat
murders two new victims and brings two
heads back to the school hoping her
sacrifice will summon the demon when she
realizes the evil spirit has left the
school behind the movie ends with Kat
sobbing and screaming into the wintry
void she realizes now that she's truly
by herself nobody will ever come to pick
her up and even the devil doesn't want
her directed by Damien Chazelle
la-la-land follows two star-crossed
lovers Emma Stone as aspiring actress
Mia and jazz devotee
Sebastian played by Ryan Gosling Mia and
Sebastian enjoyed the happiness and
heartache all long-term relationships
face eventually because of their
conflicting ambitions they go their
separate ways
five years later Mia is a movie star and
Sebastian runs a thriving nightclub one
night they lock eyes across a room and
we're treated to an elaborate dream
sequence it's the kind of ending we
expect to see the guy and girl end up
with one another and live happily ever
after
but the dream soon comes to an end with
Mia and Sebastian once again going their
own ways it's a heartbreaking reminder
that the choices we make always leave
the door open for regret before Tony
Stark made his Iron Man suit and before
Christian Bale donned the bat cow there
was Hugh Jackman as Wolverine Jackman
played Logan to perfection to the point
where it almost seems impossible that
any actor could ever replace him in the
role he defined Wolverine for well over
a decade appearing in every x-men movie
up until his blood-soaked swan song 2017
Logan said in the near distant future
Logan follows a dying Wolverine as he
uses the last of his strength to protect
the young Laura who Logan eventually
learns is actually his client a shady
scientist wants Laura for nefarious
purposes
and he has the vicious cybernetic
Reavers under his command at first Logan
is such a broken man that he wants
nothing to do with Laura and only the
aging Professor X convinces him to do
the right thing unfortunately Professor
X doesn't survive the journey but Logan
continues to help Laura all the same
when Laura and other mutant children try
to escape into Canada Wolverine makes
his final stand in the woods to protect
their escape
but even after fighting all the Reavers
Logan still must face a clone made to be
a stronger younger version of himself
with the help of Laura and her allies
the clone is killed but Logan's wounds
are too much for him thankfully after a
brutal life full of hard decisions
Logan enjoys a moment of fatherly love
before shuffling off this mortal coil in
the film's final saying a tearful Laura
gives Logan the eulogy he deserves
quoting Allan Lud's final monologue from
the classic western shame there's no
even with the kid there's no going back
right or wrong it's a brat a presence
after ending our speech Laura tips the
cross on his grave over on his side
marking the Wolverines final resting
place with an X while the past few years
have given us plenty of amazing
superhero movies
Logan was the first superhero movie to
truly make audiences weep for such an
iconic character since Thanos his first
MCU appearance in 2012 Marvel fans
couldn't wait through the big purple
body to Throwdown with the Avengers the
MCU filmmakers only gave us brief
teasing glimpses of the mad Titan first
a little bit in the initial Avengers
movie then a lot more in guardians of
the galaxy and later in Avengers age of
Ultron finally six years after Avengers
Thanos finally arrived with his Infinity
Gauntlet and Earth's Mightiest Heroes
were completely overmatched
it looks like thought was going to save
the day when he slammed Stormbreaker
into the mad Titan chest but as the god
of thunder quickly learned would have
gone for the head
and just like that with a snap of his
fingers
Thanos wiped out half the population of
the universe including the majority of
our beloved heroes along with most of
the Avengers turning to dust
almost all the guardians fell victim to
Thanos's purge rocket was there to watch
teen age group fade away and to hear his
final I am Groot adding to the sorrow of
many fans guardians of the galaxy's
writer and director James Gunn would
eventually reveal the group's lost I am
Groot translated into the word dad for
many fans Peter Parker's death was the
most painful to watch even though he
just bought the toughest villain in the
MCU Peter's still just a kid afraid of
fading away considering we know many of
the characters that died at the end of
infinity will have more solo films in
their respective franchises planned it
seems pretty likely Avengers ball will
undo a lot of Thanos as damage still you
know things are bad when Captain America
the team's most optimistic member is
unable to do anything but whisper
okay infinity war may have the darkest
ending of any major blockbuster ever
there's no moral victory no feel-good
speech for the first time the Avengers
have truly lost and it all ends with
Thanos admiring his handiwork smiling as
the Sun rises on a grateful universe
[Music]